we're gonna start with a pair of violent
attacks on religious gatherings over the
weekend that have shaken other
communities of faith across the nation
two people were shot and killed at a
Sunday morning church service near Fort
Worth Texas only 14 hours after an
intruder stabbed five people at a
Hanukkah celebration north of New York
City a livestream video captured
yesterday's shooting at the West Freeway
Church of Christ in white settlement
Texas an armed parishioner quickly shot
and killed the attacker the man who
responded is credited for saving many
lives
Mireya Villarreal is in at the church
about 10 miles west of Fort Worth Maria
what do we know at this hour
well you know right now the
investigators are praising the heroic
action of parishioners who helped stop
this gunman in fact several people
actually jumped up when the shots rang
out pulled out their guns to try and
protect the congregation we did speak
with one woman who was sitting with her
family just a few feet away from this
gunman with her 7 year-old daughter and
she says almost immediately when this
guy walked in she got a bad vibe I was
like it was like matter of seconds
that's how long it took to turn a
peaceful Sunday service into a room
filled with chaos and fear cameras
inside this sanctuary captured the
moment the gunman pulled a shotgun from
his pants shooting two male parishioners
in the corner of the church some people
ran to escape the danger while others
hid under pews
Ysabel aureole and her family noticed
the man sitting toward the back of the
church I don't feel comfortable I said
he's just you know it's giving me a bad
vibe she was within feet of the gunman
when he started shooting I tell my
husband let's go give me my baby and I
guess I got to get her out of here the
gunman was killed by a parishioner who's
part of a volunteer security team
several more members drew their guns as
well there were more than 240 people
inside at the time
this team responded quickly and within
six seconds the shooting was over church
members identified the two men who were
killed as Richard white and Tony Wallace
we lost two great men today but it could
have been a lot worse this has been our
Eolas church for more than 15 years and
she says she has no plans to stay away
we have to pray that we can get back I
have to you know thank God that I'm
alive the FBI is working with local and
state law enforcement right now they are
not releasing the name of the suspect
and they are still working on the motive
but we do know that he has ties to this
community and he has a criminal past the
congregation is planning to meet tonight
to finish the Sunday service that was
interrupted yesterday Adriana
yeah thank you so important to be
together right now
you